now for years we've told you that AOC
was a progressive fraud she had an
opportunity to meet conservative
populists in the middle on issues like
government surveillance these forever
Wars and not letting big business
dictate Our Lives the stuff we could
have worked together on
but of course she's too obsessed with
political power to do any of that and
now the liberal media they're finally
catching up a recent piece in New York
Magazine declared AOC is just a regular
old Democrat now saying since taking
office in January 2019 she's deferred to
party leadership again and again on
issues that matter even as she has made
token gestures of resistance to try to
solidify the illusion that she's a
gadfly here now is Stephen Miller former
senior advisor to president Trump and
founder of America First legal Stephen
you know she's kind of the perfect
representation of the modern left isn't
she she's kind of entitled she's
petulant she's pretty good at Tick-Tock
and those kinds of things but she's
ultimately going to bow down to the
establishment in the end yes it's
entirely a performative rebelliousness
there's no actual Rebellion there's no
actual resistance to Democrat leadership
on issue after issue she's
indistinguishable from corporate
Democrats globalist neocon corporate
Democrats look for example just recently
on the National Defense authorization
Bill she voted with Democrat leadership
to kill every amendment to impose some
kind of control on the Ukraine policy
generally voted against the amendments
to strip out the funding for the Ukraine
war she voted against an amendment that
simply required President Biden to have
a strategy on Ukraine she's done full
blown Neil
she's a neocon pro wartime well she
probably sees what's happened with
people at Kristen cinema right uh well
she's you know they just want to leave
her behind and leave her in the dust and
the Democrat Party and anyone else but
she could have actually made real
alliances with conservative populace on
these issues that she claimed when she
campaigned to care about but she's more
repulsed by conservatives than she is uh
in with any Allegiance toward real
progressivism that's the real tragedy
though isn't it Laura it would actually
be good for our country you know you and
I are conservative as they come but it'd
be good for our country to have a real
patriotic left that questioned Mega
corporations the question to oligarchy
the question of the war machine the
question by the way who's profiting from
open
borderswald is one of those people right
having that in Congress would be
actually very good for America we would
want those kinds of leftists but now
they're all the same Bland old horrible
DC Democrat that is for corporate policy
and War policy down the line um AOC has
solidified her cred I think with the
establishment Stephen with this latest
endorsement
I think he's done
he's done we have
um I do think that there are ads of
blows as there are in any present uh in
any presidency the inflation reduction
Act was a massive step in terms of our
climate agenda will you be supporting
Joe Biden for re-election
I believe given that field yes
Stephen is it just me or did she look
like she actually was laughing at
herself saying that means she looked
like she was going to burst into appeals
of laughter because she knows it's all
Bs it's the most I guess it's the most
tepid endorsement in history he's done
well given the limitations in place and
given the inflation reduction act what
is that going to do yes and of course
again we would we would we would love it
if we had more JFK Jr Stout them or crap
so you and I probably probably disagree
with on 90 of the issues but to have
people not to have higher percentage
right thank God JFK that's true but to
have people who are going to say what is
Big Pharma up to what are big business
up to Why is there censorship of the
First Amendment all the kinds of issues
that should unite right and left Trump
should go into these inner city
neighborhoods and hit the issue of
illegal immigration do not just stay in
Red State America if he campaigns do you
agree with that I absolutely absolutely
Chicago Oakland St Louis all these
places the black vote is up for grabs
more than ever on this issue after
what's happened under Biden with the
Deluge of their communities no question
yeah I said this to the DeSantis people
I said this is just Trump people it
should be no state or city left behind
spread this message I'm looking forward
to that Stephen thank you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else